vous avez passé un bon nouvel an écoutez
je fais cette petite vidéo juste parce
que j'ai je viens de vivre les quatre
mois de ma carrière les plus dingues et
j'ai besoin de vous en parler pour vous
comprenez un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé de l'autre côté de la caméra ce
que j'ai vécu - lucas en tant qu'humain
voilà j'ai besoin de vider mon sac
finalement mais positivement pas
négativement c'est bien le vide est
positif au fait je trouve son sac et on
a besoin de le faire
en juillet août dernier j'avais fait une
petite pause de trois semaines sur
youtube et c'est très stressant
rien n'est plus très simple pour youtube
heures que de faire une pause et de ne
pas mettre de contenus en ligne
on a l'impression que les autres youtube
heures vont absorber vont devenir les
mecs à la mode et toi tu vas tomber aux
oubliettes instantanément c'est
complètement con que réflexion plus
parce que c'est faux j'étais sera en
plus parce que je venais qu'une grosse
vidéo avec la vidéo des 10 millions
c'était une expérience qui m'a vraiment
remuer qui m'a vraiment chamboulé de
rencontrer les gens qui soient plus que
des pseudos bon je dis tout ça dans la
vidéo blabla vous connaissez mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui m'a
profondément marqué et qui m'a donné un
une envie énorme de me dépasser à
rentrer et de faire des trucs toujours
plus gros d'ailleurs à la fin du blog
pour ce qui regarde et je m'étais trompé
j'avais dix neo au lieu de dire nos et
william
charlène mais oh
je suis un connard voilà nos excuses moi
puisque je m'excuse quatre mois après
mais c'est mieux que ne pas s'excuser
aucun gros changement majeur cette année
je me suis mis au live sérieusement sur
ma chaîne tweet vous êtes plus de huit
cent mille à avoir foulé la chaîne tous
les jeudis vous êtes entre 30000 et
70000 et surtout vous êtes plus d'un
million six cent mille à vous êtes
abonnés à la chaîne squeeze la mer je
donne des chiffres c'est un peu nul de
karachi mais c'est pour vous montrer à
quel point c'est un truc qui a qui est
un marché qui vous a plu pour moi
commencer les live c'était un peu une
libération parce que c'est un domaine
que je connais beaucoup moins que
youtube je fais un peu un petit pas dans
l'inconnu je sors de ma zone de confort
et du coup ça m'a vraiment fait du bien
de découvrir des choses de me planter
débriefés par des potes d'avoir des
conseils j'avais vraiment l'impression
d'être en 2010 sur youtube quoi et
surtout ça permet de jouer avec des
potes au jeu vidéo le temps d'une soirée
comme je lé fais pendant très longtemps
dans ma vie mais comme je lé pas fait
depuis quelques années ça manque
beaucoup
donc voilà tous les jeudis 21 minuit
vous savez c'est une soirée qui me fait
me fait beaucoup de bien en tant
qu'humain je oublier un peu les caméras
j'oublie un peu tout ça et je me tape
des barres avec des potes et c'est
génial
donc merci gotaga merci douagbeu merci
mika d'être là tous les jeudis avec moi
parce que je pense vous vous rendez pas
compte à quel point ça me fait du bien
quel point ça me fait plaisir c'est la
fin du point live et c'est pas besoin
d'acheter si ce n'est pas déjà fait pour
rater aucun best-of foyers abonnés à la
chaîne couche pour rater aucun jeudi
soir après ça il ya eu le clip 90 versus
2000 avec mc fly cailleteau j'étais trop
content de bosser sur une musique avec
eux parce que ils sont vraiment très
très fort ils font ils ont fait vraiment
des musiques que je trouve génial on a
l'habitude avec un fake arrêter de faire
des vidéos en impro comme quand vous des
objets comme quand on fait sur leur
chaîne divers concepts qui nous font
trop marrer est trop cool mais il
manquait ce truc là on se challenger on
se lance dans un gros projet on écrit on
réfléchit on veut vraiment se faire
kiffer quatre exercices des bulls est le
résultat de sa de trois cerveaux qui ont
donné le maximum d'eux-mêmes et voilà
c'est le premier gros projet qu'on fait
avec david et raf qui sort des vidéos un
professeur et j'en suis très content
j'espère qu'il y en aura d'autres
donc voilà un gros bisou à david et raf
je vous adore les gars après ça je suis
pas chez elle en islande même si en fin
d'année c'était sympa il faut le noter
ça aussi c'était très très cool même si
la météo était complètement contre nous
il ya du brouillard
il pleut la caméra on peut assortir de
30 minutes signal
l'objectif c'est toujours drôle de
partir avec une équipe de tournage et de
vivre les choses ensemble les
intempéries les quoi qu'ils aient tous
les tous ces trucs là c'est trop marrant
aviv en fait tu sais d expérience
humaine formidable les tournages et en
fait même pas devant la caméra il se
passe énormément de choses qui nous font
grandir et qui font qu'on apprécie ce
métier donc voilà j'ai énormément de
chance de vous avoir comme communauté
parce que j'ai je peux faire ce que je
veux comme vidéo tout ce que je veux que
ce soit des musiques ne soient pas des
musiques que soient les courts métrages
que ce soit des vidéos réaction que ce
soit des vidéos je touche pas un truc
que j'aime et vous êtes là vous êtes au
rendez vous et vous vous avez l'air
d'aimer en plus et vous me montrez en
plus que vous aimez trouve ça
extraordinaire ça permet d'être libre
d'expérimenter plein de choses de qui
fait 20 fois plus que si j'étais bloqué
dans une catégorie de vidéos donc merci
à vous pour sa bien évidemment après ça
j'ai fait mon premier court métrage sur
lequel on a tu as fait pendant neuf mois
j'ai vu des gens pas comprendre pourquoi
ça méritait neuf mois travail mais en
fait la préparation la boration des
costumes les retours avec la marque pas
ce que c'est et sponsorisé par ubisoft
la construction du décor l'élaboration
du scénario faire en sorte que le
scénario soit réalisable que tout rentre
dans les frais faire bref mine de rien
c'est plusieurs mois travail mais bon je
comprends que des gens s'en rendent pas
compte et c'est même moi il n'y a pas si
longtemps des plus content de ça du
temps qu'il fallait passer pour avoir un
truc de quatre minutes quoi mais voilà
je suis content j'ai mis un pied dans le
court métrage est mis un pied dans autre
chose que juste des musiques ou des
vidéos un pro et ça me fait très plaisir
et j'espère que cette année je vais
faire d'autres choses du genre et la
sortie du court métrage sur un beau pour
moi représentait beaucoup beaucoup
après ça là la dernière vidéo de
l'épopée à l'arrêt
on va l'appeler l'épopée à l'arrêt avec
flo et oli que je connais depuis
plusieurs années maintenant et c'est
vraiment émouvant comme truc parce que
le délire autour de l'art il s'est créé
spontanément juste à cause d'un bandeau
qui avait sur le dictionnaire et et on
en a fait derrière un clip et on en a
fait derrière un dernier clip lakic est
sorti on appris le concept on l'a usé
dans tous les sens et mais je trouve
qu'on finit en beauté avec un truc qui
est beau c'est bien et on a pas fini
avec un truc en mode comme un fier vous
savez quand il ya une su qu il faut une
suite et que c'est de la merde
étudiant il n'aurait pas dû à continuer
mais je trouve que là on a bien fait de
continuer de finir vos cette manière là
par contre il faut savoir dire stop il
faut savoir s'arrêter même c'est un
concept très fort qui marche beaucoup
voilà je pense que c'est une page qui se
tourne aussi sur ça et j'étais très ému
parce qu'avec fluo lit on se connaît
depuis des années ils ont avancés dans
leur carrière j'ai avancé dans la mienne
et en allemand
maj donc il ya plein de trucs qu'on peut
se dire qu'on a en commun enfin c'est
c'est super intéressant donc voilà je
suis très heureux de ça et puis encore
une fois vous avez été d'un soutien
inébranlable sur cette série de vidéos
c'est la zec je crois que nous a le plus
plu donc voilà je suis heureux que ce
dernier opus vous et plus et puis qui
sait peut-être qu'on a montré un autre
concept avec eux dans cette année ou
l'année d'après je sais pas où l'année
encore d'après et enfin il ya eu le clip
des frénétiques lui de 30 ans après la
sortie de leur single ça y est ça marche
enfin j'ai pu mettre le clip de leur
single life philomène sur la chaîne
youtube et vous avez vraiment bien aimé
la musique pour la plupart et surtout
des jeunes et il ya plein de jeunes qui
ont aimé la musique et jeux très content
parce que c'est quand même une musique
des années 80 et c'était pas gagné mais
moi c'est une époque que j'adore c'est
des musiques que je trouve génial donc
je tripe en tant que ça faisait plus et
en voyant le clip suis sûr qu'il s'était
éclatées sur le tournage et solaire de
leur passé un très bon moment
ils ont même chacun crée un profil
instagram et ils sont à fond ils ont
répondu à des fans ils ont faim bref ils
vivent le délire à fond donc jeu très
content pour eux et qui sait peut-être
qu'ils font d'autres musiques vu le
soutien que vous leur avez apporté donc
voilà on verra ça en tout cas c'est un
très très beau projet pour finir l'année
c'était très mignon comme histoire et
voilà et voilà on est à cette nouvelle
année les fêtes sont passées le nouvel
an viens viens de passer au moins chez
cette vidéo s'est pas encore passé pour
être franc avec vous mais je me prend je
fais un tout petit peu juste un tout
petit peu d' avance de vidéo mais sans
forcer le jeu kif faire ça et juge je
suis choqué de ces quatre mois c'était
intense en termes de taf je vous avoue
mais c'était aussi riche en terme de
d'expérience de relations humaines etc
c'était incroyable et chaque année je me
dis comment je vais réussir à faire des
trucs qui me plaisent à continuer à aa
qui fait ce que je fais abstenus et à
mettre des petits pas dans l'inconnu et
tout à sortir de ma zone de confort et
là je trouve que j'ai réussi plus que
jamais ça et je suis vraiment content et
et puis voilà vos retours sont là vos
gentils mots sont là je vois de plus en
plus de gens qui ont mon âge je suis un
peu plus vieux qui m'arrêtent dans la
rue qui regardent les vidéos qui me font
leur retour et rien ne me fait plus
plaisir que ça de me dire que [ __ ] je
touche les gens de mon âge est un peu
plus vieux et je touche aussi la
génération juste en dessous je veux
continuer d'être sincère avec moi même
je veux dire à ne pas m'enfermer dans un
format à l'enfermer dans un concept etc
mais à toujours faire ce que j'aime
quitte à ce que ça surprennent
négativement les gens c'est pas grave il
faut tenter des choses il peut y avoir
des erreurs il peut y avoir des trucs
petit bide mais voilà je veux juste
continuer à faire ce qui me fait kiffer
sur youtube et à transmettre le plus de
bonnes choses possibles j'ai appris
énormément de choses ces dernières
années j'ai fait plein de
de merde plein d'erreurs je vois tous
les retours je vois tout ce que vous
dites vous en faites pas et j'essaie de
prendre du recul par rapport à ce que
vous dites mais quand même il faut que
j'intègre tout ça pour pouvoir apprendre
de mes erreurs et avancer me évolué en
fait tout simplement
après cette vidéo là il y aura un
best-of des best-of de la chaîne squeeze
live village aller chercher loin lucas
une vidéo tous les best-of ont plus de
dix minutes on a déjà plus de 30 des
best-of est en fait j'aimerais bien
faire un master best-of qui regroupe les
20 secondes parfaite de chaque best-of
lemay en revanche jacques best-of
donc voilà ça sortira dans les prochains
jours et puis voilà j'espère que
l'iphone turin vous plaît reculez vidéo
continueront à vous plaire que que moi
je continuerai à faire ce qui me plaît
et je continuerai à être sincère avec
moi et avec vous c'est le plus important
pour moi aujourd'hui
et puis merci pour toutes ces années
merci pour cette année qui est folle je
sais que je serai en débrief tous les
trois ou quatre mois en vidéo
mais voilà j'en ai besoin à chaque fois
ça me fait du bien et à chaque fois je
me dis que j'ai bien fait de le faire et
que et que je leur ferai merci beaucoup
du coup pour la fin de l'année dernière
c'était génial
et puis voilà on se retrouve très
bientôt dans deux nouvelles vidéos
nouveaux projets de nouveaux lives de
nouveaux trucs cette année que j'espère
vous plairont j'ai l'impression que tout
ça est nul à regarder et ne sert à rien
mais ça m'a fait du bien je suis partagé
entre deux sentiments opposés c'est
terrible je vous dis à bientôt de cette
vidéo
tiens les gens à bientôt pour le best-of
et à bientôt pour des vraies vidéos
voilà où je parle de différentes choses
comme d'habitude et puis il ya ce sujet
n'est c'est bien je suis gêné dans cette
vidéo comme s'il avait honte de ce que
je vais faire mais il faut pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on